der amerikanische bürgerkrieg ist gerade
vorbei und quentin tarantino verfrachtet
acht menschen in einer holzhütte
es ist ein kammerspiel in dem die gewalt
wie an wohl kran jeden augenblick
auszubrechen droht für
kulturwissenschaftlerin elisabeth
bronfen von der universität zürich
inszeniert der regisseur die gewalt
nicht zur verherrlichung tarantino hat
einen ethischen auftrag würde ich sagen
er versucht nochmal die amerikanische
geschichte anzuschauen ob das jetzt der
bürgerkrieg ist die zeit vor dem
bürgerkrieg der zweite weltkrieg die
60er jahre und er sieht als das
entscheidende merkmal für amerikanische
kultur die gewalt in dieser kultur an
brathwaite das blutbad einsetzt sei
nicht vor sophie in früheren filmen kann
tarantino schneller zur sache
si
hinter der ästhetischen gewalt verbirgt
sich die auseinandersetzung wie sich
gerechtigkeit wieder herstellen lässt
sie ist er in kinos mittel
diskriminierung zu bestrafen
in kill bill ist eine schwangere frau
das opfer nach einem kopfschuss startet
sie den rachefeldzug gegen ihre peiniger
dann besonders wichtig dass es sie eine
frauenfigur ist eine frauenfigur der
schreckliches angetan wurde und die sich
sozusagen nicht nur einfach recht
sondern sich wirklich auch im namen
könnte man sagen aller möglicher
weibliche opfer recht also sozusagen
zeigt vergeltung ist möglich und
vertretung ist auch gerechtfertigt
brauchen glorious barßels verfolgt das
motiv der vergeltung
mein name ist lieutenant aldo rang
stelle ein spezialkommando zusammen und
dazu brauche ich acht soldaten jüdischen
amerikanische soldaten gleisen im
zweiten weltkrieg nach frankreich mit
einem einzigen ziel eine reflektion über
täter und opfer es eine reflektion über
was es heißt zu überleben
es ist eine reflexion darüber was
vergeltung jetzt in diesem sinne
wirklich in einem ganz großen
pathetischen sinne bedeuten könnte
nämlich die vergeltung der juden von
denen wir wissen dass sie zu millionen
im holocaust gestorben sind
in django unchained rächt sich wieder
eine minderheit
der befreite sklave django will seine
ehefrau aus den fängen eines
plantagenbesitzers befreien
was nachher ich bin dabei wird gewalt
gegen weiße unterdrücker überspitzt und
absurd komisch tagen steht
die zuschauer sollen sich amüsieren
dürfen
szenen mit gewalt gegen sklaven hingegen
wirken äußerst realistische sie
anzuschauen zu schmerzen
tarantino will missstände hervorheben
die gewaltexzesse haben daher für prüfen
eine begründete funktion tarantino
wirklich auch dass es nicht einfach nur
um das zelebrieren von gewalt gehen
sondern dass man über eine inszenierung
von gewalt wirklich auch kritik an einer
gewalttätigen geschichte üben kann ist
es bestimmt definitiv du weißt es nicht
dafür die tiefs nicht was definitiv ist
so viel wie sicher ich bin sicher